hi one ticket for alice island please
[Music]
i'm amelia i work for nightly press this
one is my favorite it is a book about
the possibility of finding great love at
any age don't you just love that
this is not for me no problem
[Music]
mr fikry why don't you tell me something
about your lifestyle i'm 39 years old i
live alone i subsist on a diet of frozen
entrees i'm not what you'd call an
alcoholic but i like to drink until i
pass out at least once a week and since
my wife died i hate my work i'll start
with exercise okay
[Music]
who the hell are you
maya
to the owner of the bookstore i love her
very much i can no longer take care of
her someone will have to watch maya over
the weekend well it's only for the
weekend how hard can it be
[Music]
why didn't you leave her at the police
station it didn't seem right you're not
thinking of keeping it are you
there's something kind of heroic about
being a bookseller there's also
something heroic about adopting a child
thank you emilia my friends call me amy
[Music]
summer list time what is that book which
book on the table behind you if you ever
come down to providence i'll show you
this isn't like a date
is it
i'm teasing
you were so mean to me the first time we
met yeah i hope you forgot i haven't
sorry about that because i like you
enormously pretty much every bad thing
in life is a result of bad timing every
good thing is the result of good time i
just finished reading the book you
recommended this was spectacular maybe
next time you will listen to me when i
tell you something's the best well
sometimes books don't find us until the
right time
no one travels without purpose those who
are lost wish to be lost
[Music]
in all these years i've learned that
it's better to have love than loss and
it's better to be alone than to be with
someone you don't really fancy sometimes
though i get tired of learning lessons
i thought today would be more romantic
oh it's very romantic
[Music]
you